dearest gentle viewer season two of
bridgeton is practically a buzz or
should i say a wash with scandalously
hidden easter eggs and secret details
you might have missed and this author
has been honing her skills to reveal the
most truly delectable morsels to you be
forewarned spoilers ahead there's a
sneaky reference to author julia quinn
who wrote the bridgeton novels in
anthony's list of potential brides to
interview among the names he's written
in his notebook is lady julia who's
characterized as a romantic and miss
quinn who he's noted down as an
exceptional writer both of whom like the
other ladies are amusingly struck off
the list by the incredibly exacting vi
count
bees have been buzzing around bridgeton
since the show began and they're back
this season and not just in the
flashbacks to edmund's death at the
races anthony claims to best on a horse
named nectar as it's well bred highly
trained and well favored while kate
thinks he simply picked the same horse
as everyone else but really it's another
example of the show's persistent bee
imagery nectar is the sugary fluid
plants produce that bees collect to make
honey so given the strong connection
between the brigitte and bees it's no
wonder that anthony was subconsciously
drawn to a horse by that name and of
course anthony's fear of bees is what
leads to that scandalous situation with
kate in both the show and books as well
as that nectar is associated with the
idea of immortality as it's said to be
the drink of the greek and roman gods
but in the books anthony is convinced
that he will die at a young age just
like his father this season fans get to
see one of their best love scenes from
the books the bridgeton's croquet light
game of pow mao which is less about
winning than making sure the other
players lose it is a poor player who
plays the game and a wise one who plays
their opponent the tv show takes two
different pal mao matches from the
novels and mashes them up to create
their own version of this fan favorite
moment while the vi canton loved me the
book this season's based on has kate
intentionally knocking anthony's ball
down the hill and into the lake an
epilogue that takes place 15 years later
sees her deliberately create a muddy
puddle with her tea in order to mess up
anthony's game only to end up covered in
mud herself
as in the books case is the player who
gets to wield the black mallet nicknamed
the mallet of death by the bridgeton
family the mallet of death would you
look at that brother but there's an
interesting extra layer of meaning to
this in the tv show as anthony calls the
game to an end after kate's mallet of
death accidentally hits her ball over
towards anthony's dead father's memorial
stone
notice this painting in lord
featherington's study of a shipwreck in
progress which is a nice hint to the
state of the featherington family and
their finances in much of season two as
well as how terribly jack's business
ventures went overseas in america and it
also foreshadows the disastrous outcome
of his and lady featherington's scheme
to make money in london with fake rubies
after revealing penelope as lady
whistled down to us at the end of last
season this season we get to see exactly
how she goes about running her society
gossip business including how she
masquerades as lady w's maid to bargain
with the printer of her scandal sheet
printers in this town are 10 a penny
there's only one lady whistle down and
the accent that penelope puts on as she
pretends to be whistle downs made is a
nod to actress nicola cochlin's irish
roots
speaking of penelope's secret outings
notice that the blue hooded cape she
wears to disguise her identity during
her visits to the printer is a look
that's mirrored on occasions by eloise
when she visits the printers for example
to try and uncover lady w's identity in
the final episode not only is that pale
blue in total contrast to penelope's
usual style enforced by her mother but
it also emphasizes pen's close
connection with eloise whose family's
signature colour is blue on top of that
that eloise and pen are dressed alike
highlights the fact that in both the
books and the show some characters
believe eloise is actually lady whistle
down i know it is you lady whistle down
herself there's a nice bit of
foreshadowing during the ball the
bridgeton's throw in the seventh episode
when no one turns up except the sharmas
anthony decides they should still make
the best of the evening they shall be
dancing and as the two families dance
together they do so around the bridgeton
crest whose latin motto means family
before all a nice nod to the fact that
these two families will actually be
united by the end of the series after
kate and anthony marry the tulips that
anthony brings kate after she recovers
are an interesting choice of flower as
last season his mother violet told him
that tulips they symbolize passion
perhaps your bride would like the same
that bouquet of tulips is also a hat tip
to the novels where anthony plucks one
for kate from the aubrey hall gardens
which his mother has filled with them as
they're one of her favorite flowers
given the showrunner's love of the 90s
bbc adaptation of pride and prejudice
it's hardly surprising that just like
the duke simon in season 1 this season's
leading man anthony also gets a mr darcy
style scene when after sharing a moment
with kate he trips over her dog and
lands in the lake refreshing indeed come
now it is not proper to stare the whole
scene is also a hat tip to the bridgeton
books where newton accidentally knocks
edwina into a lake and anthony wades in
to help her out owen anthony gets a
bonus mr darcy moment when like the
pride and prejudice star i shall conquer
this he works out his troubles about his
leading lady during a fencing match it's
time for me to secure my final victory
for the day bridgeton's trip to the
royal races channels the mid-60s movie
musical my fair lady the way kate's
excitement at seeing the horses fly by
breaks through her usually very
controlled demeanor come now high flyer
should be separated it's all in good
spirit is a homage to how cockney flower
seller eliza doolittle reacts at the
racecourse
[Music]
and that kind of behavior also gets
prudence featherington rebuked by her
mother stop hollering like a news boy at
the start of the season kate's
appearance reflects both her
uncompromising character and the
pressure of ensuring her younger sister
makes a good marriage match for herself
and to save the family from ruin so
generally she has a more busted up look
her outfits are very structured and are
made of heavier fabrics such as silk
taffeta and her hair is more controlled
in contrast to her slightly lighter and
freer look as she opens up and relaxes
more as the season progresses costume
designer sophie canale has said that she
took cues from india for some of the
sharma's outfits from colours and prints
to jewelry design compared to the more
demure edwina who favors softer paler
outfits kate's clothes are much bolder
in color reflecting her personality and
tendency to speak her mind anthony's
sideburns were trimmed down this season
to signal how he's changed since his
rakish days in season 1 and is taking a
more mature view of his role as vika
with all its responsibilities including
his search for a wife
for penelope's gown at the diamond ball
the show's designers have said they
channeled princess of pop kylie minogue
showgirl look from her greatest hits
homecoming tour like kylie's outfit
penelope's shimmering dress has a wealth
of stars across the torso and there are
even more in her hair while pen's
costume is in her signature yellow
rather than blue like kylie's curiously
in the moonlight some of the stars on
pen's dress do actually look blue
just as each of the show's families has
their own distinctive colours for their
costumes the same is true of their
houses check out the bridgeton's home
and you'll see that the palette of blues
silvers and pastels in their outfits is
also reflected throughout their house
from the sofas and chairs to the rugs
curtains ornaments tea sets much of the
clothing in various portraits the
fireplace and even the family carriage
when it comes to the featheringtons
their ostentatious fashion choices are
all about standing out look at me
everyone and so is their home with its
emphasis on lots and lots of gold and
that includes their social gatherings
gold flowers gold drinks gold everywhere
and their home also features rich greens
and plenty of citrus tones especially
yellows then there's lady danbury's
house which complements both her own
style and her guests the charmers with
shades of pink peach and gold
season two finds eloise settled in her
sister daphne's old bedroom so there's
plenty of books and she's much more
interested in literature than the
marriage mart might i go and read now
and you'll also spot a portrait of mary
wollstonecraft whose early feminist
works eloise has been reading preferring
them to whistle down's gossip my own sex
i hope will excuse me if i treat them
like rational creatures instead of
flattering their fascinating graces
awesome craft despite her protests
eloise begins a season dressed up to
make her society debut but she still
manages to maintain a sense of her more
rebellious nature in her everyday attire
so rather than the flowery creations
worn by many of the other female
characters we often see her in striped
or checked patterns as well as
waistcoats and spencer jackets giving
her costumes a more masculine twist
according to the show's designer
there's a sneaky little meta joke hidden
among lady whistle down society papers
when the queen of gossip takes a moment
off from reporting the tons title tattle
to write a book review when lady w
describes the difference between the
author's previous books compared to his
latest it's almost as if she's
describing the difference between the
two seasons of bridgeton itself so
season one was more elusive and subtle
leaving viewers constantly guessing
whistle down's identity however with
that already unveiled to the audience in
season two there's considerably less
guessing and more waiting for the other
characters to become aware of the events
that we already know well that would
explain the ankle over her fingers now
if you want to protect yourself online
from snoopers like lady whistle down
long time viewers know we recommend
everyone use a quality vpn like nord
that encrypts your internet connection
and conceals your ip address so you can
keep all your online activity private
however with a standard vpn you can
still be tracked online by third party
cookies and those horrible intrusive ads
that follow you from website to website
then there's that creepy feeling when
facebook starts showing you ads for
something you were just searching for
like your obsession with regency houses
fortunately nord have just launched
their new threat protection feature
which blocks trackers and annoying and
intrusive ads making your online
experience a lot cleaner safer and
enjoyable on top of that it will protect
you if you accidentally stumble across a
shady site or phishing link that
downloads a malicious file to take over
your device nord's threat protection
will scan any sites you visit and files
you download for malware and if a threat
is found the file is deleted immediately
with nord you can connect up to six
devices at any one time so you can
protect all your phones laptops and
computers for a limited time all our
viewers can grab an exclusive offer on a
two-year plan with a huge discount plus
a bonus month and threat protection
completely free just visit
nordvpn.comflix or go to the link in the
video description to get the offer or
use coupon code flicks when you check
out so what did you think of season two
of bridgeton and did you notice any
little details or easter eggs leave your
comments below next tap left to discover
all the clues and secret bees you missed
the first time around in season one and
if you enjoyed this video do leave a
thumbs up and share it with your friends
i really appreciate it thanks for
enjoying this show with me and hope you
have a marvellous movie loving week yupi
kaio movie lovers